you've read about him you might have
seen him you've heard about him John
Wall bledo ahead the wall they got
numbers slam oh last year playing
sparingly now Gavin Edwards with a
rejection they got numbers dice him to
Walker not on this trip who needs a jump
shot when you got moves like kmbo Walker
Edwards wasn't expecting the pass and
he's going to go by everybody with a jam
oh kma Walker Oh what a great defensive
effort Harris passed up wall for three
there he is right now they don't like to
see that they don't like to see that
when he puts the ball in the deck goes
one on one people have the ball this is
one of them kampbell Walker got to stay
in front of them got it right there look
try to stay in front of him oh oh
absolutely Edwards right
here not close not close
to and Kentucky wins